[Musique]
pour
contre
budget 2010 8 adopter pour le conseil
départemental du haut rhin se sont ainsi
741 millions d'euros qui viennent d'être
répartie entre les nombreuses missions
de l'institution départementale
il n'aura fallu que quelques minutes
pour que le pacte budgétaire soit
accepté mais ce vote est le résultat de
longs mois de travail depuis avril élus
et agents départementaux sont sur le
pont pour préparer ce budget voté pour
la première fois en décembre
quelques jours avant le vote dernière
réunion de préparation on retrouve lara
million présidente de la commission des
finances du conseil départemental
l'élu du canton de mulhouse 3 et chef
d'orchestre du budget à charge pour elle
que l'ensemble des élus et des services
accordent leurs violons et jouent la
même partition
tout d'abord le budget c'est un acte
politique c'est très important de savoir
et c'est surtout une oeuvre collective
avec l'ensemble des élus l'ensemble des
services est évidemment selon les
priorités politiques définies dans la
feuille de route de la présidence
pour montrer qu'il ya un modèle alsacien
n'est ce pas mais
au coeur de cette feuille de route la
volonté que l'institution départementale
apporte sa pleine contribution à
l'amélioration de la vie quotidienne des
haut rhinois et au développement des
territoires
pour y parvenir le conseil départemental
poursuit sa politique d'excellence
budgétaire afin de maintenir un haut
niveau d'investissement sans hausse
d'impôts mais pour boucler ce budget un
long travail préparatoire est requis
donc on commence au mois d'avril
première proposition des services et des
élus bien sûr enjoint les services font
des estimations de recettes et donc à
partir de ce moment là on est d'abord
une lettre de cadrage ça veut dire on
dit voilà on peut faire évoluer les
dépenses sur quelles priorités
attention on a plus de recettes on n'a
pas assez de recettes et c'est donc
lunettes de grattage sur le
fonctionnement et sur l'investissement
ensuite en juillet et en août on a les
arbitrages budgétaires c'est là où il ya
une centaine d'heures enfin des
centaines d'heures de travail pour
analyser chaque ligne avec les élus avec
les services concernés etc
pour arriver en début novembre à des
orientations budgétaires et ensuite à un
vote du budget d'un côté
on est capable de faire des économies
même pour les capable aussi de conforter
les grandes orientations sont politique
le budget doit servir l'intérêt général
comme il s'agit d'argent public et qui
convient que chaque euro dépensé soit un
euro utile chaque ligne de budget et
discuter avec les élus des territoires
c'est un vrai processus démocratique et
ce n'est pas qu'une parole c'est à dire
que on a des commissions on parle de
budget on a des rendez vous avec les
élus ensuite il ya des commissions
réunies ensuite il y à des réunions de
la commission des finances où nous
élaborons ensemble une stratégie et je
vous rassure chaque élu quand il a envie
de dire quelque chose il le dit il est
là aussi pour défendre son territoire
pour défendre évidemment sa thématique
mais il comprend qu'il faut absolument
avoir une vision d'intérêt général bien
sûr et une vision globale financière -
je dois me dois d'être objective à côté
de la présidente bien sûr de pouvoir
dire voilà les marges financières qu'on
a ou qu'on n'a pas d'essayer de trouver
aussi des économies de travailler avec
le directeur général des services et
avec les services pour faire des
économies structurelles des économies
d'emploi pour trouver des marges de
manoeuvre et pour réinjecter ces marges
de manoeuvre évidemment dans
l'investissement ou dans la solidarité
ou dans le développement de notre
territoire
aujourd'hui qu'il existe
[Musique]
depuis deux ans le conseil départemental
réalise un effort important de réduction
de ses dépenses ainsi pour l'exercice
2010 8 2 5 millions d'euros seront
économisés sur ses charges de
fonctionnement
depuis 2015 la dette de l'institution a
également été réduite 204 millions
d'euros une conduite rigoureuse des
comptes publics un modèle de gestion
alsacien effectivement nous avons depuis
deux ans dans le département du haut
rhin
fait des efforts d'économies notamment
d'économies de fonctionnement du
département très important ce qui nous
permet aussi aujourd'hui d'avoir une
stabilité budgétaire et qui nous permet
donc d'entrevoir l'avenir aujourd'hui
nous sommes nous sommes prêts nous
sommes prêts pour les grands défis qui
nous attendent qui sont ceux de l'emploi
qui sont les défis de la jeunesse et qui
sont les défis de la solidarité
intergénérationnelle dans notre
département
coeur de compétence du conseil
départemental les solidarités
l'institution réaffirme son implication
auprès des plus fragiles théorie noir
109 millions d'euros seront ainsi
consacrés au rsa à l'insertion et à
l'emploi 103 millions aux personnes en
situation de handicap 88 pour la famille
la petite enfance et la santé et enfin
les seniors se verront consacré une
enveloppe de 79 millions d'euros afin de
soutenir l'attractivité des territoires
se sont également 79 millions d'euros
qui seront consacrés au réseau routier
au tourisme et à l'environnement dernier
point de ce budget 2018 et non des
moindres la jeunesse les trente six
mille collégiens du département se
verront consacré 41 millions d'euros
premier acte d'une politique
d'investissements ambitieuse dans
l'éducation un véritable diagnostic qui
a été menée sur tous les collèges sur
leur état en maintenance sur la
rénovation sur les restructurations à
faire et nous savons aujourd'hui que
pour les dix prochaines années et bien
il y aura 160 millions d'investis que
sur la rénovation restructuration des
collèges
ensuite il ya une maintenance de plus en
plus nous voulons une maintenance
performante
21,4 millions sur 10 ans évidemment pour
que les collèges 1 reste en terme
d'entretien bien entretenues pour mieux
le dire ensuite des investissements pour
le numérique là aussi c'est une des
priorités aujourd'hui une remise à
niveau du parc informatique
une intégration progressive des
équipements mobiles tablettes par
smartphone etc et puis est bien notre
priorité c'est la réussite éducative la
réussite éducative aussi au niveau des
équipements sportifs au niveau du
multilinguisme au niveau de
l'épanouissement aussi par rapport à la
culture
voilà notre stratégie aujourd'hui de
réussite éducative pour les collèges